we began development in the game that's
now known as smite way back in December
of 2010 it was originally designed to be
a game mode for a global agenda our
science fiction third-person shooter the
original pitch was let's take some of
the things that are fun about tower
defense games and put that into the
global agenda universe I converted one
of the maps into a mobile style thing I
created minions out of the Android
responders that were sort of one of the
common minion enemies in global agenda
and gave them an AI that was kind of
similar to mobile style BOTS and instead
of giant towers we literally used
turrets from the game and scaled them up
real big and place them along the lanes
and that was sort of the obstacles along
the way the game became really fun to
play so much so that we thought instead
of a game mode for global agenda this
could be a game that stands on its own
but there were two issues that we
debated a lot as a team jetpacks allow
complete freedom of movement that was
really fun but also kind of broke some
of the pacing that you'd expect in a
tower defense or really a lane based
game the second was the weapons
themselves there were weapons like
sniper rifles in the game and if I can
shoot you from that far away again that
kind of broke some of the pacing in that
sort of game so we started thinking
about a fantasy setting instead of
science fiction that's when Erez who's
our CEO and really chief designer came
up with the idea of gods and goddesses
from mythology at that point the team
shifted from global agenda to gods and
goddesses and in February we moved from
the working title battleground of the
gods to the name smite which the team
liked and his stuff to this day when we
went into pre-production on the actual
games might we ask the artist to create
a lot of different concepts using a lot
of freedom to come up with
their own ideas and our own takes and
what the archetype one be two examples
were we had everyone model Freya we had
everyone model Zeus when we came back
together and reviewed all those it was
really the beginning stages of deciding
what the theme of the game would look
like in the art style would kind of
develop from those concepts some of the
bigger well known gods like Zeus it's
it's very easy for us to find how to
approach it now as fair as consistent
lure some of the little bit lesser known
ones such as Neath you know depend on
which part of Egypt you're looking at
neath might've been worshipped for being
a weaver another part of Egypt at a
different time period she was worshipped
for being a hunter and so when we go
through our design process on some of
them we get to really pick the parts of
the lore that we think will bring about
the best gameplay or the most fun for
our players I remember when we were
first playing in alpha and it was just
friends and family and there were maybe
20 people online every night and we were
just trying to get a match going every
time and we opened that up when we went
into a closed beta where we invited more
players and that first time that you
start a match and you don't know anybody
in in the queue you don't know anybody
in your game that is the most exciting
time for me as far as game film is
concerned it's the first time people are
choosing to play the game that you
created on their own when we first
showed smite externally was in PAX Prime
in September of 2011 and impacts East in
May of 2012 the first time that we
brought the game to those shows and we
saw people playing for the first time
was really exciting it's took a
validation of all the work that you've
put into the game that's taking several
years to to accomplish over the past
year the character team has made
improvements to over ten gods and we
have our eyes on improving more Odin was
one of our earliest models and while
researching him we found a lot of
historical depictions that were showed
him as a Gandalf light character and we
didn't really think that that would fit
in to smite very well so we asked
ourselves what would he wear to battle
or
and that's how we came to the leather
and fur based version that was in the
game originally the idea behind the
redesign was to make him more godly and
regal and impressive and let's do that
we added finer clothing and shiny medals
and the elements of hanging cloth and
the strong metal shoulder mantle give
him this this quality of a religious
figure with someone calling we received
a lot of feedback from our friends at
tencent a major problem was that we went
with much more historical depiction than
the modern versions which are shown in
movies and games today now Sun Wukong is
the badass he's supposed to be he has
heroic proportions and his general
presentation is more confidently serious
like with Odin there's a higher
attention to detail better realism and
materials and more connection to his
lure overall he fits his role as a
warrior much better when we started to
rework the environment art for smite one
thing we really wanted to push up was
the fidelity so that doesn't mean
necessarily better art that just means
tighter pixel density something as
simple as the resolution of the ground
is a huge thing with conquest we wanted
to improve readability so things like
trees are much more lush hours have much
more detail to them and the bases and
bosses are vastly improved with assault
we pushed much heavier into fantasy we
knew that we had a lot of visual freedom
because it takes place in the Asgard we
depicted the battle of Ragnarok the
ground is the biggest one but anything
that's on player level has a lot more
resolution than it did before one of the
things we have the most fun with in
smite is the humor elements and then his
base level smite is not a humorous game
and it started kind of with the victory
to feed animations we started kind of
cautious started getting goofy or
started getting pop culture references
in and we found that that was okay so we
started running with that and then we
had the Cyclops who and just in one of
these scenes we kind of snuck him in in
the background soft anyone noticed and
then it just became every chance we had
if we needed somebody to be funny
someone to get bashed on the head
someone to get set on fire it was
the Cyclops the challenge for affection
smite is around mixing the aesthetics of
the God and the theme of the god with
the gameplay requirements of the God
developing a better feel for you know
what makes Thor for and how you can
convey the coolness of his awesome
lightning abilities and still tell the
player exactly what they're doing when
they're going to take damage how big the
area is going to be so it's just a
bridge between information conveyance
and coolness we build games we don't
build technology right but we've had to
build technology to build our games
collies one of our first characters but
we remade her right so one of her
attacks does an intersection it comes
from two directions so that's a
bi-directional thing that we had to
write new code for tears charge where he
knocks player up and then if he's in the
air he gets knocked up more those are
all progression attacks that that we
didn't really have tech to do but we
wanted to make sure that each character
was very unique when we set out to write
the spectator support in to smite the
unreal engine provides a pretty basic
framework for watching demos but that
was all for pre-recorded matches and so
our requirement really needed to be to
watch live matches and semi live matches
with a delay as we grew the eSports
scene in smite and got more and more
people watching and the spectator
support matured we discovered that we we
needed to add additional features that
gave data that is not directly exposed
to the players and so an example of that
would be the XP and the gold graphs that
we show in the game and we have all
sorts of stats that we want to show in
the future all of this has been a kind
of push to make smite as an eSports
something that's really enjoyable and
unique that has led us to you know
running land events at trade shows has
really when we started out pax being the
one that you look at is as where we got
our start and that's transitioned into
events around the world like gamescom
Atlanta and Shanghai as well and now
we're bringing it all home to our
backyard here in Atlanta where it will
be the top teams around
the world competing for their share of a
hundred and seventy-five thousand
dollars and more as the prize pool
continues to grow to celebrate the
launch of smite and hopefully the first
step towards a continued growth of
eSports